RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
UKRAINIAN EMERGENCY SERVICES NOW
SAYING 33 PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN
THIS ATTACK.
JOINING ME NOW FROM KYIV, A
UKRAINIAN PARLIAMENT MEMBER.
IT'S A WEEK INTO THE INVASION.
YOU'VE DECIDED NOW, I KNOW, TO
ARM YOURSELF AND FIGHT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
FIRST OF ALL, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN SEEING AROUND
YOU?
>> WELL, WE HAVE SEEN, FIRST OF
ALL, LOTS OF AIR STRIKES AND THE
AMOUNT OF THEM HAS INCREASED.
YESTERDAY, THE DAY A STRIKE AND
MISSILE HIT RIGHT NEAR THE HOUSE
WHERE I'M LOCATED RIGHT NOW, AND
THE WAVE WAS SO STRONG THAT I
FALL DOWN THE CHAIR AND IT WAS
PRETTY UNPLEASANT.
HOWEVER, WHAT MAKES ME REALLY
GLAD IS THAT WE ARE STILL GIVING
PUTIN A REALLY GOOD FIGHT.
AS CITIZENS OF KYIV, WE ARE
PREPARING FOR SIEGE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT HIS NEXT STEP
WOULD PROBABLY BE TO SIEGE THE
CITY.
AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE CREATING
THE STORAGE OF THE SUPPLIES, OF
FOOD, OF WATER, PHONE BATTERIES,
CHARGERS, ET CETERA, SO WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO FIGHT HIM HERE IF
NECESSARY.
AND WHAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW IS
THAT EVERY TIME THAT THERE IS
PEACEFUL NEGOTIATION ATTEMPT,
THAT MEANS THAT WILL BE MORE AND
MORE MISSILES GOING INTO
UKRAINIAN CITIES, BECAUSE WHEN
PUTIN SAYS THE WORD "PEACE," YOU
NEED TO ARM YOURSELF AND MARCH
FORWARD BECAUSE IT EXACTLY MEANS
THE OPPOSITE.
IT MEANS WAR.
WE KEEP ASKING ALL OUR
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS FOR THE
NO-FLY ZONE.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
HARD THING TO DO, BUT AS A
POLITICIAN AND MEMBER OF
PARLIAMENT, I KNOW THAT THE
RULES ARE CREATED BY THE PEOPLE,
AND PEOPLE CAN BEND THESE RULES.
PUTIN HAS NO RULES AT ALL.
HE DOESN'T CARE IF HE'S CALLED A
WAR CRIMINAL.
HE DOESN'T CARE IF HE USES A
FORBIDDEN WEAPONRY.
HE DOESN'T REALLY CARE WHAT
HAPPENS JUST IN KYIV WHEN 63
PEOPLE WERE KILLED JUST WITH ONE
SHOT.
SO, IT'S EITHER LIVES WILL START
FIGURING OUT WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT US FROM
THE SKY, OR THERE WILL BE A VERY
HARD-FOUGHT BRAVE UKRAINIAN ARMY
TO FIND THE TROOPS ON THE GROUND
BACK, BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT WE
CAN DO.
WE DON'T EXPECT ANYBODY TO FIGHT
ON UKRAINIAN SOIL, BUT WE EXPECT
SOME HELP FROM THE AIR.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT THAT
EVEN IF RUSSIAN TROOPS OCCUPY
KYIV, THAT THERE WOULD BE A
PROLONGED AND SUSTAINED GUERILLA
FIGHT AGAINST AN OCCUPYING ARMY
IN THE CAPITAL CITY?
>> OF COURSE.
WE HAVE CALLED IT RESISTANCE
TROOPS.
WE ARE GETTING READY.
WE KNOW THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE RIGHT NOW IN KYIV WHO
ARE GETTING READY EXACTLY FOR
THIS SCENARIO.
WE ARE NOT GIVING UP OUR CAPITAL
WITHOUT FIGHT AND WE ARE NOT
GIVING IT UP WITH THE FIGHT AS
WELL.
WE'RE GETTING READY TO OPPOSE
RUSSIAN TROOPS BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN WHAT THEY ARE CAPABLE OF.
WHEN WE WERE FIGHTING THEM FOR
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS ON THE EAST
IN DONBAS.
SO THAT'S WHY I KNOW UKRAINIAN
MEN OR WOMEN, THAT'S WHY WE ARE
GOING TO FIGHT THEM.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION
TO WHAT UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY JUST SAID ABOUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS FOR OUR VIEW
AND HE RECOGNIZE FOR YOU.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT, I WANT TO
TALK WITH PUTIN.
I THINK I HAVE TO TALK WITH
PUTIN.
THE WORLD HAS TO TALK WITH
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO OTHER WAYS
TO STOP THIS WAR.
>> DO YOU AGREE THAT A DIRECT
DIALOGUE WITH PUTIN IS THE ONLY
WAY TO STOP THIS?
>> NO, I DO NOT AGREE WITH THAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT DIRECT
DIALOGUE WITH PUTIN WOULD LEAD
TO ANYWHERE.
IT'S JUST AN ILLUSION THAT WE
ALL HAVE THAT YOU CAN TALK TO
THE CHEATER, AND HE WILL CHANGE
HIS MIND.
HE WAS VERY CLEAR.
HE'S REBUILDING THE RUSSIAN
EMPIRE.
HE WAS VERY CLEAR, HE'S
REBUILDING THE SOVIET UNION.
SO, WHAT EXACTLY ARE WE GOING TO
TELL HIM TO CHANGE HIS MIND?
I DON'T THINK THAT IT COULD BE
ONE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY TALKING
TO PUTIN.
IT NEEDS TO BE LIKE A LONG
TABLE, THE ONE THAT PUTIN LOVES
SO MUCH, WHERE ALL THE NATIONS
OF THE WORLD, THE LEADERS OF THE
NATIONS, ARE SITTING AND HE'S
SITTING ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE.
THAT, I CALL TALK, BECAUSE THAT
COULD BE A DISCUSSION THAT COULD
AT LEAST MAKE HIM RESPECT THE
RESULTS.
HIM TALKING TO PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY WOULD NOT LEAD TO ANY
CONCLUSION.
IT WILL BE JUST ANOTHER ROUND OF
PEACEFUL NEGOTIATION